when did beastmode start when did this
whole beastmode phenomenon occur was it
when you were a kid was it when you were
an adolescent oh yeah well I mean you
know it it kind of grew with me mm-hmm
from Pamplona ya know those manchild
involved as I got a little older and
then I mean high school collagen is just
stuck and now it's just like y'all
somethin you sure yeah very well now
it's a t-shirt yeah you stick with
something it becomes a t-shirt kids
that's the lesson but here's what I'm
curious about you you have met you have
met a lot of people in life now who
aren't necessarily they're not athletes
they have regular jobs but they tell you
that you inspired them to bring
beastmode into their professions is that
true like it happened to you at a
Starbucks or but what hap the young man
was mixing mocha loto Lockett I read
every word but the motherlode was over
so I might a yeah so you know he's seen
me in a line like oh man you know I'm a
big fan and then he just flip a switch
like I'm going beast mode Megan did he
make like for work I think they got
machines just early
you don't think of someone going into
beast mode and then making a latte but
it happened but it does happen it does
happen and that's inspirational for
people it's inspirational for me can you
control beast mode or is it like the
Hulk it just happens does it happen to
you or you can make beast mode happen oh
you know what I your beats my right now
it you had no idea you was in it and it
just happened right so this I think is
just like a party yeah it just it just
do what it do yeah I mean he's only SMO
24/7 myself I'll believe me uh there
were retirement rumors dude why are you
laughing at me I'm a very serious the
hair it's at least
[Applause]
you say like it stays like this I take a
shower and I get out in two minutes
later it's a Wang
look at that it's right back I'm coming
at you I think we got to get a shirt
yeah you better put that on a shirt on